what shall I do here what's my very very
very first step oh thank you well done
ten points to Gryffindor okay now always
do that never just like before we were
noticing I when you solve the equations
before you even stopped working before
you start working you know restrictions
when you draw a diagram all those kinds
of things with solitarius equations
labeling them is exactly the same okay
before you go anywhere all right now if
I'm doing this by elimination you'd
notice by the way I could do this my
substitution I suppose I would maybe
divide this equation by two or this
equation by three or etc so that I can
isolate one of the variables a being
that this time I've chosen to do it by
elimination I have two choices I can
multiply two different things
I take equation one I have a choice of
what I can multiply it by what are my
two choices let's get someone else is
you you've been really good so far
have a look you can choose two
differently to multiply this by that
will both work yeah genuine here we go
okay two and three let's have a look at
this
why would I multiply by two well how
would that be helpful if I multiply by
two I'm gonna end up with 6x minus 4y
equals 22 is that going to be useful to
me now but it might be useful depending
what coefficients I have in the second
equation right as it so happens at the
moment I look and I see you later for
that's not going to go to six that's a
three that's not gonna go to four so I'm
gonna need to go to another option and
the other suggestion was three three
will work right why is three useful
what's the feature about the second
equation that's actually going to help
me here yeah reno 3y fantastic so I see
that this doesn't have a three in it but
this does okay so three works what am I
going to get I'm gonna have 9x minus 6y
equals 33 okay
this is gonna work cuz I'm going to be
able to do something here yeah I'm not
gonna pursue it you tell me why in a
second why I'm not going to but what was
my other choice it's not - what else
could i x that will still work but it's
just not that great yeah for very good I
have full also work for the same reason
the three will work it's just that it
will mean I will eliminate the X instead
of the line I'm gonna avoid that though
I can think of at least two reasons why
I'm going to avoid the four can anyone
tell me why any one of the reasons
number one it's a bigger number I know
three and four
you know relative this thing but they're
not always so clean-cut okay so number
what it's a bigger number and other
suggestion anyway I want to avoid that
it's a pretty minor one if I were to
multiply by four then what I'm gonna
have to do to these two equations is I
will have the same number of X's here I
here I guess I've had 12 X + 12 X right
then I'm gonna have to subtract the
equations in order to cancel them yeah
so I'm gonna have to I'm just gonna try
I told you yesterday right
I avoid subtraction wherever I can not
because anything wrong with it but
because it's error-prone every time you
add an O Negative every time you add in
two - that's gonna multiply by another -
you're asking to get something wrong
okay so that's why this is a better
choice this came for equation one so can
I have a suggestion for what I should
name it one a that's okay
in just the same way I'm gonna have to
multiply equation [ __ ] in order have
something equivalent I'll multiply this
one by two okay so don't forget to
multiply every single term that's
another easy error to make what you're
doing the elimination method B that that
came from equation 2
I'll call that 2a so now my stars have
aligned I have the negative the -6 1
here the plus 6y there so now I'm just
going to add the equations together
adding is always a better way to go so
I'm gonna get excuse me
17 X here my Y's cancel what do I get on
the right-hand side
pledget and don'ts
okay so X is gonna be equal to now
before you look at it and think I need
my calculator for this one okay
sure get you calculator eventually but
you need to exercise that muscle
otherwise it's get atrophy and there's
an easy way to see it must be seven
right what's the easy way to see that it
must be said that because you look at
the nine you're like what can multiply
by seven to give me a nine on the end
it'll be seven by seven times seven is
forty-nine right and then I've got some
extra and then you mentally check it out
seventy plus 49 yeah it works okay so
it's an easy division don't reach for
the calculator if you don't have to okay
just like before I'm going to take that
and I'm gonna substitute into any
suggestions where do things the best way
I actually think it's kind of equal here
one gives you smaller numbers but you
got negative two gives you bigger
numbers but everything's positive a nice
tip just because you asked for it let's
put it into one so what am I gonna get
there 21 yeah I've got a big over there
so check out cool there you go